What a pleasure to have you here. Thank you. This is a mere Morrill of a different me show.
Called what is missing.
I think about twenty five years ago I had an idea.
I work in series as an artist usually three S. five sometimes
seven and returns have been three times seven when I cheat and.
I
knew I had at that point worked on a memorial for
war civil rights women's rights the women's table at Yale
and
I wanted to start on one for the
environment because ever since I was a kid I care deeply about the environment and.
I got pulled in to do a very in-depth project on the Pacific Northwest by
the Native American tribes along the Columbia
River and I put off. What would
be come what is missing I I mention it
and boundaries with this idea it was called the extinction project and I didn't really get started on
it till I got a commission to the California country sciences to make an
artwork and as opposed to just making an artwork. I made them two.
And the second one was the beginning of what is missing your
interest your interest in zoology you include you know made this in your interest of interest or not are you.
I would say ever since I was a kid grew up in
the sixty's
seventy's and I mean it was a wee wee in gauging time
whether it was the Vietnam War civil rights issues women's rights
issues and for
me grew up in Ohio Lake Erie catches on fire you have
really the formation of an establishment of the clean air the Clean Water Act
the Endangered Species Act by nine hundred seventy
three and it really had an oppression on me as a child and I actually
went to college to study fields who already.
You know. And so I've
always cared about the environment. But you stopped at that point because. It's a source
of
us. Morning to you. Well I was given you know you enter
college went to Yale and you were given an advisor. I was
given this wonderful science advisor. Actually he was
an acoustic Jim Dr Robert Apple and. He said you know my
and the animal behavior program. You know is is neurologically
based and it involves a section and I didn't really know what that meant but when I
found out I was sort of well this might not be what I'm quite interested
in being a bit of a nerd. I was sort of nervous because I
was thinking I'm going
to go into this and I remember it was. Freshman like entry
day and looked up at the ceiling of all the hall and I thought
well what about
architecture because it's sort of bland art and science and math
because I kind of like I was a bit of a polyglot and so I go running over to the
architecture department and the directors that go away come back at the end of
your sophomore year because we don't want anyone to come in
and specialized go out there and just follow whatever interests.
There are so I took everything from the geology of the Long Island Sound to our classes just.
And then applied and went to the Major.
But I think it's interesting
with this passion of users never very. It's
very little but time always
and yeah and I think I'll just remember as a kid my
parents they kind of wouldn't let us have pets it wasn't that they were
like against pets I think my mom just thought you know that pet was not in their own language
like we had a cat once for a little while I can't remember what happened to
it so I was recently I was like I don't want to know what happened
and
I. We were in a house surrounded by the words
this concern really
stupid. And I would sit in the
lawn and I would sit really still till
like I could get like the rabbits to get kind of close or the birds would like
come in they my dad always said that they kind of train east of it they would come to the window when
they wanted me to feed
them or I'd open the door and leave a trail of peanuts into the house and the
chipmunks and squirrels would come in so I've always loved animals despite the fact that my parents were a
little bit horrified by you know what are you doing
anyway yeah so I always
want the natural world.
Going to look at some images of the I Q two to come with them we're going to look at the
last images just preparing you for voyage. Yes through my
aliens would. And let's begin
there through this is called the listening town. It is the
first installation of what is missing.
The idea of what is missing is what if you could make a
memorial that could be in as many
places as it was invited in it could exist as
temporary installations permanent
installations it exists as a website what is missing dot net that will exist as a virtual in
a physical book and to me it frees long as you share it. So this
was at Renzo Piano he was designing and
McAlpin Academy of Sciences this is were I had an Art Commission I
built an outdoor wire landscape of the San Francisco Bay on their western
terrace and Renzo was like well you can use the extreme of the Eastern
terrorists here the thing about his P.R. has Heaven forbid you would put an artwork in one of
his P.R. says
so so I was out of doors and I was very
interested in using sound and video but I'm out of doors.
So in order to make a piece. That would engage visually as well
as with sound. I had to create an enclosure and so this.
Listening counted sort of based on the R.C.A. Victor kids sit inside the reclaimed
Redwood wood and listen and
the B.B.C. National Geographic and Cornell and dodgy labs
donated sounds. And we started doing this
research and we've right now what is on the scene has produced about seventy
five one to two minute educational videos about
species habitat issues and then this intro clip is what
is played at the beginning
and what do the human
because the very first thing they'll hear is an animal sound or sound of a
habitat like the whole rain
forest and we're very
visual so the idea
was twofold. If you
can't see it and you hear it first. Your your brain kind of clicks on
to a different way of a relationship and you're also very curious. So I'm always trying
to wrest the visual and then the still not always stayed in like the one you
saw of the loon. And you begin to read it first before.
Again you see it so the last thing you see is the visual and then
the text as you go through it
it's never me. Another thing that I thought would be very important for
me to do with what is missing is to act as a frame
where we're quoting from all the
N.G.O.s all the scientific groups and what you begin to see
is to see this group as a family
and to see their gains and their losses this show's.
Creative Time and the M.T.V. billboard creative time got me the M.T.V. billboard
in the month of April in two thousand and three and we again
created four
one five minute films that talked about different things that were missing. So
again it's not. Just the species of the habitat. They need but it's also not just
an individual species. It's the entire group of sea turtles that are risk all
the great apes are at risk all the station in the ocean and ninety percent collapse.
This
is our website you can see a lot of dots and.
You can click View in time where you can see it Jill a good question extraordinary to go
on each one is a story of the natural world there
are timelines that show an in-depth like a hundred point history of
a city or a
river because what happens is you the
people whiffed where there was great abundance the first thing that goes
through sewage pollution and industrial and then you see the arc of
recovery were laws come into place. So again that link between conservation
in Travolta beginning to protect and then like in New York
Harbor the seals come back the first
will cited. But what you might not know is
that you know in the sixteen eighties.
Adrian Vander donk accounted for was trees that were six feet long.
I don't have a lot of those here have and of G.L. offend your right to
choose
but that's good we'll go to that but basically So what do we do.
We ask you there's some note cards please take one but then you owe me a
memory. At a personal
memory if it's something you remember that your parents or your grandparents told told
you about diminished natural abundance.
Or maybe some things come back because the phenomena
that scientists refer to is shifting baselines injured diamond refers to
the landscape did nature is that we accept what we
know we don't
remember that cotton rewards are than men in the eighteenth
ninety's we won't know how
abundant shelves this were so that they almost purified Chesapeake Bay
every day. And that someone would build is the churning of the water
was
from the shellfish queen and so basically are we doing this am I doing it to depress you
know I'm doing it to make your jaw drop open that.
Natured the natural world is capable of that sort of abundance and actually nature
is incredibly
resilient and if we give it a chance it comes back. So part of
the part of it
is to engage you and to get you to realize what's in your own backyard. What you
can do
and then the second part is what you can do as
individuals as well
as what you can do with moments more macro thinking
and so we're working on the last two years. It's called green planet which will take
that white at night for you and rearrange the lights
with economics in mind with urban planning in mind with with
agricultural footprints in mind so. So it's kind of a I kind of went off the deep end and I've got two
more years of I would say fairly nerdy research work would you enjoy
that I do would you almost
like I would say fifty percent of my mind is on Messina at any
given time it's a volunteer project for
me and I just feel if I could make
one little bit of difference here I'm going to I'm going to
try and so this is what you were talking about earlier. How important the text news
and a lot of the sources are around that isn't your boy yes
it's never it's never my voice but I don't think it's ever been my voice. I
always love you I or any of your projects. Well I think it's a
funny one I think I love presenting factual
information and then generally what I'm after
is your response to it. The thing that makes missing different. Is there is a
whole side of the website. So this is like this is where I go normally it's
like elfin depletion I mean we're basically able.
List of all the animals that are in a ninety nine percent ninety seven to ninety nine
percent crash whether it's bison or sea turtles or elephants
or or whines or tigers I mean it's incredible. What's happened and you
might not realize this and and I
think we've lost my train of thought world as I go and you knew going. But this is
sort of of still not only do we ask for personal memories.
We have volunteers historians.
Our researchers finding incredible accounts of
natural abundance. We've got the very
first accounting we think of Plato and prettiest and he talks
about the hills in Greece and how bare they are and how they were
once forested sometimes you know
we get about to be the depressing part which is the role. It's
depressing except for the fact that and someone said we'll do we do we have time
to
be depressed and what will depression really do I think it. Hopefully will wake
a sense and say hey I can do something about this. So whether it's choosing
to. You know to consume
organic shade grown fair trade coffee which can support one
hundred fifty species versus twenty to thirty in a plantation. There are so many
things we can do in our consumer choices as well
as the kind of green print is really going to focus
on. The intersection between landscape
reform agricultural restoration prevention of
deforestation coastal development
how those all together the changes in Wendy's if we reform
those
practices would be equivalent Thomas forty nine percent of all carbon emissions. So I came
up with another film. You can go to the website it's called and
shopping actually. And it's basically we can save two birds with one tree.
So I think we have to move very quickly to reduce climate
change missions
and a great way to do it is to restore and protect habitats
so facts like you know where one requests are three times as much carbon
as a tropical forest and with climate change happening so
rapidly. It's our best line of defense against rising sea
ties and how many times are we going to rebuild in the same location and we build and rebuild.
When if we just are a little bit more logical
and say hey we created in return coastal wetlands in certain
areas that are
just at really the
brunt of the hit in move back a
little we create a buffer zone for us a massive
biodiversity gain and so that's sort of what we're beginning to play
with we say things like if you took the entire world's population
today with seven billion of us. Living at the density of
Manhattan not such a bad city to live in how much space to
seven billion people take up living at the density of
Manhattan proper and then click the slide and it's the state of Colorado.
So again we love to share what the scientists are doing what
the experts are doing but as an artist. Maybe I can get you to think outside of the
box or to rethink what the problem could
be you. You see in relating your experience in college
you said I loved logic Mts computer programming I love
systems and logic approaches and so I just figured out that architecture is this perfect
combination and it takes me seven years of architecture school to
realize that I think making markets. What does it mean to
bring back
about why I think I think whenever you get up and. The whole architectural training
you actually get
up in front of your class
in front of critics and you basically
have. I tell people why you do what you do all the time all the
time and in our I think it's the zap opposite.
And it doesn't mean that one's more logical than the
other we're making choices and everything we do with
we're sculpting our
paintings but we're not going to attempt and you would never dream to attempt to
delineate and explain why you're making that mark over that mark. So I
think the two sides of me and for some weird reason I think I ended up
with Bozo the left side
and right side of the brain there. They're a little bit for both and so was for better or for
worse and for richer and
poorer. They kind of are diametrically opposed
at times and I'm I'm living in fear and I think the memorials are that in-between
ground because and I'm really trying to solve problems in yet at the same time you
have to let the poetry come
forward Piscator one said the two kinds of mindless proof you
know simply speaking to G M E T that to finesse and Geo
geometer A and in some sense the two
cultures came together in you and you then they're not
really fighting. They're not buying and trading but the but interested in the threshold but there's like
a
tension or I don't know whether I actually don't think there's any tension it's
like I don't know I'm you could say I was always interested in the boundary area between
the two states but I actually love
architecture for its sort of
programatic functional aspects and I love art because it's
the exact opposite you just talked about the move a proven poet. Yes and I and I
think the
great fear and I think what I have to balance
is twofold one we've tended to live in a
very Ever since the industrial era we like to
compartmentalize so I was labeled as an architect and it took me years. Years
to figure out the I was they would call me much more
intuitive which I
think implies like there isn't a reason to what you're doing. I think there's just as much reason
but we're not going to speak about it we're not going to be able to define we don't lose any
more labels you know the labeling also happens
because of the people you bring us right it's a mixture you
know Napoleon once said to one of his generals he knew everything but nothing else.
And sometimes a very good sometimes very dangerous ways when we put in the small word that
was one kind of memorial resort. When I have seen marking then I would like to
to go through the landscape of many of you may remember it was
just a Civil Rights
Memorial Montgomery Alabama built on commission by the Southern
Poverty Law
Center and they called me
up I had graduated from grad
school and I could not believe when they asked me that
there wasn't a memorial
to the civil rights era but at the same time I was very
reluctant to take it on
because I was hyper aware of where
I was in my life and that if I took
this on
the labeling it would be just two fold but at the same time pride
for the same reason I designed the Vietnam while I Does the side of me that
has been very drawn to.
History and learning and maybe it's because both my parents were
educators and the fact that I didn't realize until I started reading
about the civil rights era.
And this was like we were living through it and I wasn't understanding it is a kid and
I didn't realize that someone
was murdered for using the wrong color baton.
I didn't know this movement. I remember. In the eighty's I
think Eyes On The Prize come
out and people understand it but if you were growing up and being
taught history in the seventy's that was almost too soon.
So part of me is realizing at that point
that if we can't remember it.
How how can we even
learn from what the reluctance was and so that you would be speaking to some of the Arabs
whose name.
No not at
all it was more the I just didn't want to you know
my whole life
that's she's the kid that designed the memorial. So doing another one is going
to different stance shoot that but at the same time I just felt
especially I start
researching it takes me one or two years to to research and
I didn't presume to
know what the historians knew. So they assembled the
Southern Poverty Law Center assembled everyone from Julian Bond to historians I can't
remember the Roy eight. And my only.
My seeking for this was I knew very early on this this couldn't be just
about the martyrs the people killed it had to
teach a
brief history. So what you see at the beginning and it's
a it's a sundial effect it's a clock in a
way. And there's again we have are there to look a perfect. There's
a gap because with the Vietnam it's a book and the timeline
meets beginning and end of the war and meet with civil rights. There's
a gap signifying the time before in the time after that what we captured here was from one
thousand fifty four Brown versus
Board of Education to sixty eight Martin with the King's
assassination as kind of the Cold
War. The history of what they would determine was this the civil rights
era at which point what you've got
is legislation. Have riots. You have someone's
death someone's death is sometimes caused because of legislation or right.
But you begin to see as you walk around the the
timeline that this was a people's
movement that there are I think I can't remember how many
names but someone's death triggered either better legislation or
the attempt at better legislation led to a riot led to someone's
murder and as you walk it by intertwining individual lives
lost with leisure special. You know political
events you begin to see how they're connected
and the worst of it was and I'll never forget we had to sit around the
table
with the word murdered Lynch. How many times you could say killed.
How do you do it factually How do you make it so you don't end up since satiate lies in
it because again I'm a firm believer
that if I step off my balance and I
become
emotional. And if the context becomes too emotional then
I'm not trusting the
viewer. To react and respond to it.
These words when you read them for the first
time arrested
you say you know I find down to
Montgomery on the first trip reading eyes on the prize and reading something I can't remember.
And before I landed I came
across Martin Luther King quoting from the book of AMOS We are not satisfied we shall not be
satisfied until justice rolls down like waters and I just this is
that intuition like you research something you put it all aside and something
just hits you and I knew the piece would be about
water before even the land it and I'll never forget it was the proverbial you sketch it out on a
napkin you give it to Morris Dees
and Richard Cohen who I just saw and you just know the piece would be
about that quote I don't know why.
But
this is a recognition that happens
something strikes you and you don't know why.
And I don't want to know why I can you know when
I but it's also what's what's interesting in your process for me is that
you immerse yourself in a lot of things that you know little about at
first and is such a pleasure. Not knowing.
The historian where much of my name kind of Ginsberg who said that when he started his
research he starts from the point of view of the euphoria of ignorance.
Yes absolutely and that it's something
that I think we share but I mean it's certainly something that
I I adore about what I do which is very speak to people all
the time who are so different and each time I have to immerse myself
in the I work as I did with you and here you are immersing
yourself in this worked and then you come upon that quotation.
And you know and you know what the book would look like in the woods in the way
he made the work realized in that fashion.
Yeah and also there is a site and that's Julian Bond and
Rosa Parks so it was an incredible
moving. Dedication and I think McCann It
was you
know it was the pause it was packed. But there were also.
State troopers on the rooftop because they were sort of afraid of
perhaps neighbors. I mean it was a little bit interesting I
mean you feel like you've participated in parts
of history that you almost can't. Describe in a way and then
someone staying to it but the whole crowd
just hushed because they thought maybe something happened. It was just the
heat of the day. But the funny thing with me is once I'm done with a project in this is a terrible
thing I kind of have to move on and right now
I am so my head is like my brain is ready to explode with facts
about sustainability and economics. Not that I can spout too much now but
just it's odd I compartmentalize and then I have to move
on and I've always been that
way but you you know you approach things
from you were mentioning earlier on that you were new dads you were growing up.
So you approached things wanting to really want to
understand what it is you work in museum
and it grew mines we have this idea that you want to get
to immediacy after
reflection right but it's
also you. I write a lot I research a lot I mean writing I'll just leave
shots down like there's been clues are
out in the book like the women's table I think I just wrote a spy of numbers to start
up again and then I basically have to put it all
away and then I usually go to the
site but then again with some writing.
Sometimes I begin with the writing I think for the sculptures I think the sculptures are with the ones that
I often don't but the whole body of work is about sort
of studying terrain topography. I'll begin with
ideas of what I might want to try to say and then it all goes
away. And I wake up one
day and I usually it's after I've seen the
site with the women's table it was really funny
because they would call it three like three months
going
anything. New career. And then one morning I
woke up and I made this little model and it also lightly reminded me of a
Modigliani face off on our on a base. I mean I
knew the timeline would be there because again I'm I've been obsessed
with. Time in all my works were in the memorials.
But I didn't know the form that one
took a long time so for these works I don't work on
deadline because I don't believe well what if I had a
deadline and then I had to find a form before it found me.
I know that sounds a little strange but I kind of believe. Yeah. With
all that research at some
point so I put it all was something and something happens at night you
know when you Felipe or whatever you dream or whatever and it'll pop up but heaven
forbid because of the deadline. I had to force something out too
soon so I kind of I need that percolation
time for the for the memorials and I think you know missing.
I'm nowhere near even though the website is up it will keep on
changing it will keep on involving I write about it at the end of the book it's a
grill artwork in many shapes and forms and
but at the same
time have I done what I do normally no because I'm still so
much in the research mode and I've got two more years and then what will probably happen.
Well two more years because I think that's how long it's going to take me to to do
enough on green you're going to move.
I've had internal deadlines and I've been meeting the deadlines but the stripping down because
it's some point I'm going to want it to end up very
pure and more into pure poetry but not yet I'm not ready for
that because that's sort of the final and all the research and I tend to write a lot of
book with to understand what a project is so with missing will end up being like all of these
little bit of booklets that help me
see what I'm doing or trying to do but it's still
fairly obscure I kind of apologize for it at the end of and of
apologies work in progress girl are. It's kind of I'm building it in full
view and I keep.
Morphine it every every day I tend to surface on Earth Day because
otherwise you know I hide back about my hall.
So this is my month of
getting the word out about what we've been doing with missing and.
And then I'll keep on working on it but we'll get back
to missing I'd like to take you down different projects.
Do you use very different
than was I you know in architecture and again because
I do
art and the large scale environmental artworks in the shows. I'm
very careful when and what I take on an
architecture and it's very humble at times and for a moka Museum of Chinese in America which
is downtown. I have been trying to help out. Not for profit
organizations that I like or I believe in and so with Mocha my
mother would be so proud issue alive she sort of thought I probably
took thirty five years or forty years of kind
of not being exactly embraced scene of my
Asian identity culture and I just
decided again how Porton it is. And
again it might be because as I've grown up I realize
this kind of dual identity has probably played into my
feeling of love of the opposite. So museum a Chinese in America. It says it's a
twelve thousand square foot museum downtown renovation of an old machine in
the World XI workshop. That is.
I'm on the board help them out ever since keep helping them and we did it on a shoestring.
And I'm relieved I was doing architecture when for causes
from groups that might not have a lot of money but to me it doesn't mean you can't you can't do
something. You brought up your mother. And that she would be
proud of you
you could fund this magnificent quotation in that in an interview that you
did has been more years many many years
ago when you say you know I think my mother was born
in Shanghai. Oh I think
and she
was she was
you become more certain about that she would have been proud of
this of me kind of connecting to you as an angel sent to
the cultural identity because I think. And again and I think
the little bit of a phenomenon with immigrant parents both my mom and my
dad came from China.
They fled as communism comes in they met in the States and they
never talked about. What it was like growing
up they never talked about it we never brought it up they would say well you never
were interested and we would say how could we
be interested in something
you did memory you know. And so one of these cans twenty two so I don't believe in
the return of the repressed you got incredibly And yeah we got really interested in it and so this is
just the interior and there's a hidden courtyard and we were able to walk
you around and again here comes the time line the inner courtyard which of my God.
The first time I visited the site it was buried you couldn't even see the sky or Accord
or and the whole narrative history the arc of Chinese
Americans coming to this country which actually starts very early on walks
that timeline and the film portraits you
see that was done with some local projects. And
management and matter the design from
literally Chinese immigrants have come out in waves. So in a
way the reflection of what was going on in
China as to why they immigrated in
that part of China. Coming out was very
different sort of like someone coming
from England or something Thomas and Spain but it's all considered China.
But
what people don't know is that the islands were different why they came out the entire cultures. So
as you walk it you see this history revealing itself but as
you go down to the classrooms in the offices down below you actually
see the changing face of Chinese immigration through the
different eras as a family so I never thought I could play as much
with time and in a weird way some subtle symbolism
in the architecture so this was sort of a sweet project to
do my and let me take you on a on a journey which you know the novels for you OK but it's a
memorial that is incredibly important to me given my
family history.
It's a memorial that an Israeli artist then the caravan did for then
to Binyamin and it's impossible to write the border
between France and Spain.
He never made it and there's.
Great discussion whether he committed suicide or not but
this you know this with more I do know this incredible. Let me let me show you.
The uniform.
Yeah I like that reaction. It is incredible to be
there
nearly escaped and so you you have you have
that the sea there.
And the beyond which was not reached.
It reminds me a little bit in a very very different but there are aspects of this
to Pinga son's memorial to that
supported it the tip of the ill the last detail. In Paris.
Which is what I've read the
words which was very moving and something I
had studied. Were
basically you have the names past a certain
point you can walk into this one area. God I can't recall
the quote there but it's a similar thing but all of these in a
way are about passages that you can get to a certain point.
And then you see beyond but we're not allowed
to attain it whetted me it's a little like Hades. It's you Richey
it's Orpheus
Descending having to turn around and come back that we're
not allowed. So these are
all there is really our Gorakh all these writings and a lot of ways and I you know
what I think. The
Vietnamese face the same way it's this. I mean there isn't a view the ocean
but there is the reflection. So you see
yourself in through a mirror darkly.
And you see yourself reflected in the names that this one it's all about the expanse but
again we're
not allowed
that that change they're trying to tell you
with yeah with Lieschen says it's from the concept
of history that Binyamin wrote a few months before dying.
It is more difficult to honor the memory of anonymous than it is
to honor the memory of the famous.
The historical construction is dedicated to the memory of
the nonmembers.
Can you say then
again you have to start it is more difficult to on of the memory of the non
the mess than it is to honor the memory of the famous.
The historical construction is dedicated to the memory of
their moments right.
Most beautiful. It's to me though in a very funny
way the most moving memorials. Whether it's the memorials to
the
missing in World War one. Well you brought up.
Or
what you just read. It's of all about absence and it's about there
is in impossibilities that you absolutely can attain So this
is
this memorial which is Legends a memorial to the missing interior Paul France.
Is
very directly connected to my
design for the Vietnam
Memorial not so much formally
but
but two fold on this if you go back one
image written in on the white
stone are the names of I think over one
hundred
thousand soldiers killed in one
battle over. I think it was a three day period in the battle of the
some and they're all missing.
Why are they missing because there are no dog tags.
So I
had the you know. One Everyone knows the story. I designed
the memorial Vietnam
while as a class project in the class project as a senior at Yale.
You
have.
You have an option you can set up your own classes seven of us said we're interested
if you know the architecture the design we did right before
we decided let's let's design the Vietnam Memorial there's a competition that's a great word
in school the assignment was to design a memorial to World War three.
And so I had started studying all about memorials so you get back
into the thought about the same as versus the missing or
the
individual up until I would say the World War One memorials in Europe.
Memorials were always about the victor and frankly always about the
leader the foot soldier didn't
matter because up until modern times
individual lives soldiers one.
Really accounted
for got the man on the horse. We
won you get to except
for like the civil war in the U.S. We're
brothers from you know both sides were going to be listed in the town was
the memorials to World War One a war commission
was set up the wives lost I think it was
a one out of three. One out of four men in
Europe and because there were no I.D.'s so many were missing
and you see and I studied there were
books put out we found a couple of the early volumes. These were
so powerful and I didn't quite understand why but I
just you know aside from the fact that they listed all the names but
these were not victorious these were like Vincent
Scully described this is almost like a gay teen
scream that was a bombed out church in the town and this memorial was
in a way formally very much connected to that but
what happened was I had then designed the last project
after finding this in as I'm thinking about designs for World War
three
memorial. I had designed the memorial.
And class was about to end or class it ended and Scully
if you go back one in the spring semester
I designed it in the fall of eighty. I had a
senior seminar
with the NZ unscholarly and he starts talking about how you
go up to this memorial from the opposite side you have to cut through.
A
simple one of grass so you know what violating that space you get up
you're inside this gaping screen you're working
now on one hundred crosses and a hundred tombstones of the
British and the French you're not allowed to go down
into that space that you have to now turn around and go back and as he's
describing this journey to an awareness of
was and that again there you have it you can't attain it.
I'm starting to write furiously in what I write I end up writing on the
boards that I would that I'd then decide to submit because. I just wanted
to kind of I don't know make a statement but
that's sort of why this piece has been so important to me. Vince was always a
little curious because for me they couldn't be more
different but then I finally wrote about it anyway.
You
see at the memorial it's tapping
into some very important. I would say
ancient
needs. Yes.
Very I think again as you as you are starting
in how we mourn. I was very
acutely aware how America's very young.
And we tended to be very afraid of a gene of
dying that earlier cultures have always not just embraced
death but that the dying is so much a part of a
ceremony of wife that there's much more of an acceptance of it and up more of it maybe not
in is part of
life and that we're very young culture and we almost hit away
the age you feel because of that. Yeah I think it's used so I think we're just a very
young country still are maybe we're going through are all kind
of are you know. We have such screen tricks suppressions you know when you want to
see in the American English language is something you see relevant.
You see that's history right. We have no use.
It's rather high and no I mean I think it's like think of it like probably right now we're in
our
awkward adolescence and you know as a country. No we
were very afraid and you
know so I designed this thing
and. The names.
BEGIN and END. The the apex sort of the closed book.
So it is that close timeframe. But again what you have is.
Not so much an
object inserted to the earth but I've always seen the site you cut the earth you polish its edges it's
a geo. But what I've really done is by going down ten feet at the
apex you create this quieting sensation as you go lower
and lower the sounds of the city because Constitution Avenue is right there it's really
noisy actually that drips drops
away. And you don't have a sense as much that your going.
You're descending but the names are rising up so
psychologically and you were kind of walking
into another world that you can see it's like
that image of our world again through
a glass
darkly. And then you have to turn around and walk into the light. You have to turn
around and walk back. So it is
that journey turn around. With whatever you do so you write your future and
I
think obviously for me the fact that
I made it a chronological wish to
name again.
Is all about the reality of the time
and again trying to capture the factual. Nature
of the situation. So any
veteran who spent time in the war would come back
and within one or
two pages. Of that was
the find their time and of course find their colleagues. So even though there
are no names aren't there they are there back in their time units and I had to
fight really hard because first they really did not want the
name chronological they wanted them. Alphabetical because they
thought how are people going to find the name they're going to stick
time to work and I said well they will want to take that time because that becomes a
ritual of understanding and of remembering. And then
I keep all reads remembering also that the word remembering is really
remembering putting the members back together.
Absolutely yes and I and I also think it's
like a name brings back everything you know about the
person. So is it really that
abstract the timeline makes it actually very real and a funny thing the time it's
important and
then it's also the scale is hugely important the lettering is
like less than half an inch high. So what you've got is a book put
out in full view but it's still a book and we all have to
read books one on
one you see I like to think of my work as
creating a private conversation with each person no matter how public.
Each work is and no matter how many people
present rush to to my mind it's very consonant with his
idea book because yeah. In some sense we're never more alone than we were
when we're with the book I'm a more
compromise and it's very personal and yet no matter how public so I don't actually think of any
of my works in terms of how many people or how public a space
is I'm probably like that.
And that's all I'm after is what one person is going to do when they touch
or experience. One of my pieces and touches that's important units. You
know you can't see it without touching it in my
opinion.
Right
I just wanted people to. Know I like
to think everything I do you know I try to say I just have to touch that I just have to see
it which is interesting because museums as we were all about not.
I know it's like now you get a sense of this is for me at least for sculpture it's like you want everyone to
like connect to it was the first. Yeah that's you know it's pastel dry
and I think one of the jurors said he must really know what he's doing to there to do something
that he had the any idea. Of you know.
When he was I was I was still in college when
it came out so yeah it was sort of
interesting anyway a long time ago when you expect. Do you do
you ever wonder what would have happened if this hadn't happened to you.
You know
you were Yeah of course we all do it's like you know every
time you have a moment in life and you take a different turn. I mean I
think it
probably knowing that it happened. I did everything
I could to pretend it hadn't by going right back into grad
school and I
think I'll never forget I got
out of grad school pop to the next slide and see
what's next now after that now. Either way. Either way
guys now.
Shawn and scarce know you can't go to then I want to get past them was
yeah. Where was
I You were asking me to go back
and forth. Oh yes I want to get past. Yeah people
we do want this is interesting. Oh.
Interesting to me is where I think it is yes I think it is when you think it is
where I think it is I'm sure
you. This is from Beijing. OK.
It's amazing. Story beer.
The family story has a family. You must tell it.
Just too extraordinary and also the fact that in your family
you're carrying around this region see for memorials
in the most central location when possibly
imagine this. So this is a forbidden city or no it's not it's the
big tournaments. He and a minister and my
on the
eldest daughter of
my Qur'an and
father my father's half
sister.
That was a certain time in China and my father was the
first born son eldest son of the Serb wife.
Lynne way yeah. Is that what I wanted you to
get my. On to Lin way yeah
and very well known very beloved in China
almost like it's the soap operas about her and T.V.'s and movie says about her
is the daughter of the second wife and there was a
first wife who had no children.
So everybody was obviously in the way even I had
a architecture teacher at Yale King Louis Woo who came up
to me and said I.
I mean and he still had a crush on her and and
managers adored her and she was she married lengths to change but she had
a certain magnetism to the point where they both came out to study architecture in the
States. To get to you pan and she's told well we don't accept
women and within a year he's teaching at the school she just
had something with her
and this is it she was modern She was
smart she she and her husband end up cataloguing
a lot of the ancient. Architectural style of China they went all
around documenting it that manuscript was lost for many years their
friends Wilma and drawn their banks found it and published it. It's got a pictorial
history of Chinese
architecture and she and her husband
reign
in the States they bring modernism back to China. There
are firm nationalists they believe they were going to go
back and help out China and they pretty
much helped engineer Tiananmen
Square and she created this monument in in Tiananmen Square.
I think she also had a huge say
in the Chinese flags from certain reports.
I didn't know about this history. My father
though adored. His sister
adored her and so desperately wanted a girl.
So my brother's born. Brother's older than
me and he.
You know he wanted a girl. So it's very not the Chinese like the assumed.
The father wants the son it's like he just wanted the girl because he's so adored win win.
And then I you know. Flash forward we're in
D.C. it's some function he's come in and my dad is talking
on and on with the then ambassador from China and at
the end I'm going What were you guys talking about and only then does my
dad begin to reveal the
family history I think. Grandfather helped draft the first constitution in
China that I had this aunt and she was actually well known too and it was kind of
this
interesting.
Piece that was not in my life and what piece missing. But there was a
whole undercurrent were my father was just
so in a way it's almost like he gave me a sort of strength because I
almost got this favoritism.
Sorry time. My
brother because he was just so adoring of her and it was just
it was sort of in a very empowering. But again that history was
kept from you it was absolutely. Yeah
yeah except for the fact that anybody that he almost empowered
the daughter to have this sort of favorite son status that was a funny
thing to be in what I thought was really funny is without knowing it.
We
were connected. Yeah you know. And I remember
a history professor at Yale Jonathan Spence was like telling me
and showing me pictures of Groucho wonderful men and.
And it's it's
just kind of a funny irony.
You know so this Chinese president is discovering also Japanese
yen sensibility. In this project. And somewhere you know connected
to I think I never could figure out how much I responded much
more in a way to Japanese architecture to its simplicity until.
My mother and I were in China this is one of my first art installations so
this is one thousand nine hundred three is for the Webster Center for the arts. I
was invited to install a permanent work first permanent work I think at the Workers
Center and the Webster Center was designed by Peter Eisenman And he
combined two grids go back one
slide and do. When So if you walked into the front
entrance and one level down in the cafe you were met with a concrete
and empty ninety feet wide kind of an impossible residual
space filling up with cigarette. Whatever the wind would blow
in and I had been working in my studio with broken glass which you
could never put it out in a public space because it's broken glass it is tempered glass but
it's technically still not something you
could put out where kids could play with it and I took one look at the space and
I said I know exactly what I want to do forty three tons
of broken car
glass. And White having a
glass because broken car glass with Gouin it was tinted green
and then the patio glass again
recycled was white and I had
the color it was called Color the recycled color guys poured
into these massive dump trucks equally on both sides
so that when it would pour out in these
buckets with the crane bucket. When I get
the color of water which is what I really wanted to do I gave myself seven
days. Working with the team.
To make the piece
with barely a sketch because as I once I got out of the grad school. I
began to
realize how much I was splitting my time between my
architecture and my art and it's probably always been this way full
disclaimer my
Japanese do you know fine I know when to be really you
know. More the disclaimers that your father was was a ceramic
rather misses and he
was the school of art was my playground so I was like casting
bronzes by the time I was in high school and I just I don't think
I ever was not making something but my mom was a little bit of an academic snob it had just
a bit I would go into something
my dad was doing because he only got a man. It's just to be nice to get a doctorate. So there's
a really academic
side and then there was my dad it was like. You know cigarettes being cool being the
SO wellness this and the two sides are like oil and water at times
I don't remember in what passes you talk so movingly about your
father's Oh yeah it was in boundaries
and he.
He was this incredible ceramicist and
he could pull upon the lens of his own
arm beautiful slender always ceramic goys
where Stone pottery glaze wears
and. I grew up with him having that ability and at a certain
point he gave it
up and he started first and became director of the
school of art then he became dean of the School of Art and I couldn't figure out how a potter
was so good at balancing the budget and. And he was really tough like I think
they were all so happy when he retired because he always got the most money for the school of the
art at Ohio University and what again. He never offered and they would
say we never asked. He fled China mid
career and when he was a teenager or high school or.
He really wanted to go into ceramics his parents had an
incredible ceramics. Collection that when the Japanese invaded.
A lot of it was
taken at that point and he wasn't allowed to so he goes into
academic administration and becomes like Secretary of fukin university he comes out.
He's
probably almost forty. Goes to University
of Washington start studying
ceramics but he was trained as an academic administrator. So you get
stone you hired as a ceramicist and little by little move
back into. DEMICK administration. Partly because
he liked it partly because he wanted to make more money so he could
put my brother and I through
college and by the time he returned to ceramics
after he had retired he had developed a little bit of our writers and my dad was
a perfectionist and he just made all these
pots and he never glaze them because he just they weren't good enough for
him so we still have them and one day when I run I always talk about who could we
get to work with us so maybe glaze them or maybe it's best to just
leave them with you and ways. I don't know it's probably they just
sit in storage meetings is something I don't know what. But he was
an incredibly skilled
ceramicist and his hands were so I was when
he'd passed away I was not there and I rushed out and I got
to the funeral home and I just saw
him lying in state and I just walked in his hands and this was
a
tough could be very formidable like the jeans. He was
a tough teen and. And I always thought of my dad as being
very kind
of we would yell. I mean he would yell it.
Professors yell it but President to get more money it's like he was a tough guy and I'm
looking at his hands and his hands are
incredibly
delicate and there are incredibly elegant and they're incredibly long and I
just looked and
I I just realized I he gave me his
hands and you just see this guy is being like this cool
roughs kind
of you like the from B.P. has never looked to the fans like oh
my god they're like So how again would you know it was discovered that I know it was
a very strange moment because I'm sort of like.
You know. Tragic. I'm really torn up but at the same time it's like you're making
a connection and I think we just don't
know you can live with your pain. You don't know who your parents are because we're
just when we're kids we're just not looking at life that way and maybe when you
have kids and you reflect back. But yeah that was a kind of
an amazing man to look through a number of things quite quickly
in the interest of because sometimes this
was part of the first thing was left of center and then I've done. Maybe five six.
One woman shows and this was part of a show called systematic landscapes where
I took a mountain range that I knew that I hike every summer called Blue
wakes and I pulled it apart and this in a way
is directly inspired by some of
John McPhee
S writings where he talks about going through. I don't know if it was the Cumberland Gap I can't remember who
was in Basin and Range where you're driving through these cut and the way
the sedimentation
has been up and lifted. So often as opposed to seeing the stratified WAYS OF
THE EARTH WIND flat. They've now risen up when you're driving
through and the stratified waves are now almost perpendicular to the
your ground plane. So if you go back one and see the detail. This is out of
formaldehyde free particle board and I took the terrain map
so I created this topography and I deliberately
stacked and had plywood the metal
glued vertically that way and I
left just enough space about thirty inches so you can kind of fit
through the maze and each each piece is like
thirty six by thirty six so the massing is larger than the space between
and you kind of get wedged through it as you
go through it and when you mention someone like like John McPhee You know those writing.
And so far you know the word. Yeah. And
so I had asked in to apologies. Because I couldn't resist
boundaries which was the first book I wrote because I really felt writing was almost
like sketching for
me this is the Caspian Sea which is again
we're very visual a lot of my artwork focuses on natural
phenomena but again maybe getting you to think about something you're not thinking
of and we tend to think of the surface of the water we're really thinking of what's below. So
this began to play with pulling in the depths of bodies of water
and sexually part of a series called bodies of water. This is a piece
I just completed it's still up at the Renwick there are a nagual
reopening in our
first the Renwick is our first museum and if you go back one.
It's the Chesapeake Bay It's called Fold in the
Chesapeake but the Renwick is a very historic building and I
took one look there are nine artists in this group so it's the show's called
Wonder and.
And I just took a drawing of the Chesapeake that I drew I folded
up the edges of the paper and I said well what if I just ignore the architecture of the room
and just let the piece flow from the floor to the walls up to
the ceiling. You can pop to one more.
And so I don't know if there's a third one that details now go back and it
is about.
I love in my are to kind of look at
waterways terrain. So in a funny way. Sometimes I'm a bit of a
cartographer I go to the Strand I buy used atlases and.
It's a little like I don't Matic drawing but how does this gum surgery on
me made me think of what you saw in Yarosh
a lot for allies and so I would say
about twenty years ago fifteen years ago I started buying up used out.
Says and what I love
is you follow follow with an exacto blade.
Landscape
terrain up until you get the to the United States and ways in
which we could measure by hubris just measure us
square cities states territories followed more
natural boundaries.
So the idea is once I start drawing and you're kind of following
both the natural borders
and political borders and then I'm just making a
landscape within hidden away in atlases. Again and then
this is
the pin. These are pin Rivers waterways. This is at the
U.S. consulate in Beijing and if you go back
one it is the Yangtze River. So
I like looking in and grounding
people in what is literally right under their feet.
I also love focusing on rivers because we tend
to again we're incredibly territorial we we see what we
know and we know along the river where we live.
Maybe if someone's polluting upstream we'll think about what's up
there to start to what was the good don't get you know we
don't tend to worry about what's downstream from us so a lot of these rivers and waterways are
beginning to get you to see these rivers
as unified holes.
And this one I love. Again underwater to rain this one was
called waterline only the top two feet was
above ocean level it's the I want to Bouvier and it forms this
complex terrain and I just. Again I think eighty five percent
of the world is covered by water our most complex mountains
are underwater the tallest mountain in the world. Isn't Everest it's Hawaii.
And so often times in my
ARE I'M TRYING TO partly I just want to look at it because
I'm just paying attention and then partly I want to tweak people
because again if we can if I can suspend disbelief if I can get you to look at
something for the first time again were
a very is a chance.
Interesting because when we're kids we look at something and we
really look at it we miss we're we've never seen it
before so we spend a lot of
time fascinated by really simple things and as we grow
up and as we know
more we absolutely. Stop looking because we already have this
background of
knowledge then when I was receiving it. You need to use yes to respect its
immediacy its empathy
is that your moment of experience and it's
very non restaurant schol especially in the art but
even within the history works the memory works.
I'm just trying to get you to see a pure fact in front of
you rather than referencing it to something outside that was around and I think
a lot of the minimalist artists. I think it was Robert Morris wrote this
great essay called the present tense of space Irwin
talks about it in our Weschler talks about it once was
heard and seen forget it seen as forgetting the name of this thing one sees if you can
arrest any sense of reference and you can pull
someone into
that immediate. Pure experience and I'm drawn to
that when it's in the stars unsure of soils so.
I don't know what's Well you know you because you were talking about
childhood a desire. You know the right.
You will mention MORRIS There's a line in human veil I've always loved we should close
with pension reform with pray you.
Write anything is it will help you type of you can get lost in the moment. You're right you're getting
lost and you hope for it.
Yes always and I think partly I want
to I want to get lost in that moment I'm a little hyper. I'm a
little way
hyper so my work is a lot
calmer than I would ever be it's really sad because that's how you have to write
through all right I'm so tired because it's one thirty two and
I will never know if I wanted to show we have been doing and when he
goes yeah this is I just completed it you get a sneak
peek of what's inside but basically no one else will for a while it's Novartis
is research labs in
Cambridge that we have built the only architecture project I took on from two
thousand and nine till last year I'm now working on Smith's library
in Northampton if you go back one.
So and go back another now go. OK So this is a good side.
So the start of it there's a lower section because everything along mass I have
is four stories and then there's a taller tower which is all the research
labs and from the beginning I based the entire patterning which is
that stone it's a floating stone sunscreen
wall the stone is Chelmsford it's literally quarried fifteen minutes away
from downtown
mass and it's patterning is based on a
microscopic view of bone.
And if you go back one what I was trying to express was in
medicine. Scientists are
always learning from nature taking from nature and then
systematizing nature. So
the pattern of the glass
tower. Is almost up patterning it's got seven
different levels of fritted glass to begin to get that play of depth.
It's all in one plane and again it's this kind of symbolic I will do you
feel that what we learn from in
Nature Medicine does exactly that it. Then tries to
make compounds tries to make scientific sense of it and then the heart and
spirit of the building is you've got the whole lower what I call the boomerang section if you go go
back one
time. So everything on mouth there. This was the
last on built a band in this parking lot area a
long
mass between. MIT and Harvard.
Cambridge wanted everything on the street to be given back.
As we tell to bring life to the city which was great but then how do
you make a front entrance to
this building so that whole canopy is your entry into
Novartis into a public park. It's a one point five acre public
park during the day anyone can use and then it's a compound of to leave
buildings that I sort of designed the first building
which And then the second building is to seek a mores and the
third is a two story structure that had to remain
its with any
computer. Was invented. So you
had two stories for stories and then we could go to eight stories so I had to
again very interested in keeping the scale of the story and the human scale
of
that street taking and not overpowering this two story historic
building and then still going of course of artists to
build a research and for me it was an articulation between conference scene and meeting
rooms down below and then this is just the sneak peek of the inside it's
of Sadia that how do we
get. The goal. What one of the major goals was how do you get the scientists out of their labs and.
Out of their silos and talking to one another or so the whole the
whole the
whole what we call the war
Boomerang has all those meetings conference and the whole place becomes a very almost a
campus like socializing field. You can go on and talk about larger scale. Yeah
yeah a Levon minute wine.
Very interested in taking a little bit of
Ohio in transplanting it to southern Sweden.
Because I'm
from southeastern Ohio and there are these
incredible effigy mounds of which one is literally called the Serpent Mound
and it has a snake about to eat in the Hague and when
the European settlers first came
to the new world and they saw these mounds and they
went well certain way that Native American tribes here could not possibly have been
this this is to Katyn Europeans must've come
from Europe. Made these and then gone back to Europe.
So what I figured I do and I get very interested in
the nature of a line drawing like this one to me was the little
prehistoric I wanted to take a little bit of Athens Ohio and move it to southern
Sweden it's
the part of them the fact my sister is a state everyone
else has their artwork. There's an incredible barn that Anne
Hamilton to over. Martin
Prue has this. Unbelievable statue almost boodle like
shape hidden in a Beech Grove. But I just needed more
space so when I do these large outdoor works I need a little bit of elbow room go
back and so I'm very busy. This was the here.
This was a cow pasture and it was owned it's one of the oldest.
Operating dairy farms
in all of Sweden and so I asked.
Marie. Can I Can
I play in the field and just sort of water now. We have to ask
the what do you call that the dairy man. If the cows
would mind
and it sort of brings back memories of
your childhood. You know you your father and mother thinking that you
knew when to feed the
animals yeah and then there I am where you are again in a state of the art
sustainable organic dairy and the cows actually love the climate and walk on it.
Don't know why. So this is another piece part of
a series called The Wave guilds there's three in
this series they'll be three in the earth drawings and they're all based on I
came across this one
photo of a repeating water wave in this is the second called Flattr it's
a very shallow wave. It's when water comes almost to shore and
it causes ripples in the sand.
This was the first in the series it's ten thousand square feet scale is you could
sit back and look
to fast. Just mind. OK. You
can sit in a wave and read a book and go to the last of the culmination of this series
because this is all plain about scale you can go pop forward Storm King wave
field and
again I think the reason I end up making so many of the works in the studio is because when
you're out there and full scale. They're not letting me near the
bulldozer operators it's like they're going to we're sculpting
it. But I
can't do it my hands aren't doing it at that point and so this was just
the beginnings of it and we
built the whole piece out having modeled it model that this is the Storm King aren't
center and I realized once I built it. I had gotten the scale wrong
for the site. The idea was I'd go from ten thousand square feet for the first wave
feel thirty thousand in this was ninety the ninety thousand wasn't big
enough to fit the site and so we had. Then increase each
wave by about five feet. So it went from twelve feet to eighteen feet and in doing
that every single row had to grow.
He was great. That's my at this moment in
time I'm basically saying I think we need to scale
the project up which meant every wave but the
first had to get done. He smiled and said sure.
The
remounts later. You know and so this was I was driving up the Storm King like
almost every other day to help.
We held our breath and we had to talk about the library in the library
and talk with you
brother and yes my brother tahn is when my older
brother is a language pilot
and I spoke yesterday to a poet to to me is a very good
blues very good poet in these are much smarter than me.
Really intellectual too
and but really for your father. You had to do exactly what
it my mom who's a poet and a professor and my brother were like perfect and my
dad and I were off making clay
things. My brother probably
was instrumental we all talk about how. Our parents influence
us my brother did I mean he would put out like easy poets like Merwin
and then came Ashbury and then came Stevens and I could tell
you what they meant but I just fell in love
with. Poetry in high school
and always just was inspired
so and we knew so extraordinary in terms of trees and nature.
Yes I was out there playing in the woods and my brother was writing like crazy
and so this is called reading a garden and the title of the piece is spelled backwards
on a water fountain. So when you see the
reflection in the water it spells itself. Forward
and it's my brother's poem and it's a child's verse it's almost like Alice in Wonderland
because
this space was between the old historic library in a new library in the children's
school library was right at the base of the new library. So we created
this three part little.
Home game garden that you playfully walk through or
on and it's just called reading the garden and
and there were be times where I created the form and then my brother wrote the
poem and then I would change the form
because what you didn't want to do like with anything I'd done before with civil rights I came up with
the form and then applied the words with this piece I wanted to start saying well what is the arc.
What is the space changes
to the
language
and so this again and this is sort of my idea of how I start thinking of like the spiral
me is a beginning because it was women it yell. It's not a
memorial it's just merely.
Kind of commemorates co-education at Yale and on this water
table is a spiral of numbers starts with zeroes and that with the year
I put it in which is I think ninety three and of course
when there were no women at
Yale at the beginning. So it's a bunch of zeros to you get to like eighteen
thousand eight hundred seventy whatever. And there is the number thirteen.
And that's like the first graduate
school to admit women it was a Yale School of Art Street all in the rumor
was though I've also been told that's not true Mr Street had two daughters and he gave money
to build St hall under one condition that it decodes from the start
and
so again here's a timeline the last of the way the timelines
and it's completely open ended because you can have a beginning.
You know when yell starts to admit women but you don't have. And the time
that I came across one
book and they gave women the names silent
listeners because women were allowed to audit courses at the start but they
weren't allowed to enroll. And then one officially. Admitted women into
the undergraduate
class they did so under a very strict quota. So what we
tried to do and I had to use the Yale strict statistics department
and there's a footnote. I love it if I can put like an ass tricks but
no on an artwork because the stats department said
well we can give you an approximation. But it's an approximation. Because in the Yale
School of Law they officially admitted
women but they didn't want to admit they admitted
women. So they left them isn't this all.
So they don't know how many women and they had to do an
extrapolation
on the initials to assume what percentage may mean.
So there's a little footnote on the back that sculpture that kind of because the stats departments you have to
you have to like to explain as
you know looking Yes you mean a source who is thinking of the recent
past and
just how I mean how much of this is me
people speak
about the poor create a few architects of the women.
It's amazing the number of women that train in architecture.
In my whole training
has been at least. You know forty percent fifty
percent sometimes more at times and then it's really hard.
They don't end
up becoming their
own firm. I've seen we've been architects get
relegated
to the managerial
rules versus the creative and you don't know why.
In closing my. A project that is very close to you.
This is
the well these are sculptures this was at the Paris This is AROUND THE WORLD times three in it's
the Arctic.
I was going to miss latitude. Introspecting New York and then
the equator. So this is the terrain above and below sea level and then if you
go on I'm very interested in just again the mountain
ranges I'm really interested right now
in the deepest crevices in the ocean as well as there was a headline
that came
out three days ago about you know the and.
Antarctic in the Arctic. The
Antarctic disappearing this is this is go back one this
is the diminishment of the Arctic ice cap.
So it's lost about fifty percent of its mass
what isn't told is it's the amount of debt that has been lost as the ocean
waters
underneath are carving it out so I think a lot of the comments are
from the scientists is they had to be
very conservative. That's just the nature and their role.
It might be the concern is that this is going to happen much faster as the ice
starts melting and and a Swiss cheese effect starts happening. And if you go I
think if we pop to the next one this
is I took one piece
of Vermont marble and yeah. Always you're allowed
to touch this and week out of one piece we carved out. So the
uppermost layer
layers were what's left. So if you go into a detail of it.
So this is called the disappearing bodies of water and like to show the air of
the Lake Chad which are almost nonexistent as waterways so I'm
very interested right now and diminishing our call for is
in the polls. I think I'm beginning to start to build.
Words. Than that show which will try again i was take two years.
You know as I hope to be able
to use you back to the library
because I'm going to probably be doing a big project with the
the Danish royal library on the Arctic
Circle is seventy where my meeting
subject and politically. If you can believe it.
How many countries are now battle when.
Because they think with all the ice disappearing they can go
ocean exploring for more oil or have a I mean we're we're
we're insane. Well you know I mean we don't do that in that sense art
and I'd like to see come together for you
as with yes in the art and maybe it's always been that way I think I've always been a little bit
on the political side. I just try to be
Nanda Dak To kick step with Messina or I become a little
prescriptive hopefully when I'm done I'll strip it back to something else but part of it will
remain extremely prescriptive extremely didactic I'm not going to get
out there with missing telling you what is gone without telling me what we can do to
help
because I think it's our
time our kids are going to suffer it. It's not going away to our
grandkids it's now and we have to move and so this this is what young
people in
Mount one week ago today.
Yeah and I thought clipped it and I'm into that made with
obsessed with like right now I'm going to start working on a sculpture that deals with
they have all the data
of of them the mountain range underneath the Antarctic.
One of my piece is going to be about an
Antarctic without ice not that there will always be ice there.
If if and when the climate models are saying it's going to once it starts it goes quite.
Quickly I think though there was one ice shelf the Weddell ice shelf in the
Antarctic it first signs of thought when it went it would
take decades and
it can get within two
months and that
was just two hundred twenty years ago and other people filmed it was
stunning and so when the Antarctic goes I think it's going to increase
sea level by twenty feet but the trouble is that the Arctic
going and Greenland that could really set us over. So this is happening
in
our now and it's again as Al Gore would but when you put the
lobster in cold water and you turn the heat up slowly but you
barely notice that So again we have a very
weird inability to see something happening right in real
time when it's kind of not immediately fire
to put out it's a little bit of a
slower situation and that's the problem
and also with shifting baselines we just don't realize how much
is change because we just accept what we what we have in front of us. So yeah
I'm obsessed. I'm really I
mean this is it's this it's ocean of things that if occasion it's
it's the sixth extinction
it's all happening. But I'm ultimately I
mean I'll say it it's
like the World Economic Forum said it would take seven hundred billion
annually to curb climate change
missions. That's less than what we spend annually. On cigarettes
or I put up another factoid you combine what we spend on the weight loss
industry and. I can't remember any meetings in the US that seven
hundred billion meetings in the US. You
mean people going to meetings going to meetings which I've always wondered. Yeah of course one more
thing no two
more or forget this. If you want to protect all of biodiversity it would be
like seventy five billion a year and that's what we spend on pet
food on that new plan that we know very well you're going
to.